[Music]
hey Uber yes yeah uh you're Marquez yeah
it's me
great it says here in New York City is
that right yeah New York sweet
what are you going to the city for uh
work for work
ah of course yeah what do you do for
work
all right we're doing this uh I'm a
YouTuber yeah
foreign
hi so my name is Marquez and I am a
YouTuber which is a pretty well
understood job at this point but I feel
like a lot of my peers don't like using
that word just because well it doesn't
fully explain all of what we do it's
kind of like painting yourself into a
box a little bit but also there are some
connotations to that word in 2021 and it
also comes with this baggage of having
to explain what exactly that means and
what you do and how it works
so that's what this video is that's I'm
going to use this video to just answer
all of those most frequently asked
questions this video is going to answer
the top 10 I think that I get asked the
most often and so I'm gonna send this
video to anybody who asked those
questions in the future maybe you will
too
enjoy
[Music]
ah
okay so so what is a YouTuber what is a
YouTuber and I feel like you kind of
have to start there right because you
know maybe you and me were in this world
we know YouTubers exist and we know the
Creator economy is bigger than ever but
there are lots of people who are not in
this world who don't know that so
fundamentally I make Tech videos and put
them on YouTube but behind that there's
a whole delicate balance with an
algorithm and search engine optimization
and content strategy and there's a whole
lot that people don't see that goes into
it but behind the
iPhone 12 review you see that comes out
in September
it is a job okay okay
but also okay so how how do you make
money how do you make money ah one of
the classics how does that make money
how do you make money
so it's a little different for every
Creator but fundamentally I'd say you
could divide it into three different
buckets for every Creator on YouTube so
the first bucket is just the ads that
you see that are built into YouTube so
this is one of YouTube's biggest
advantages over every other video
platform but the ads that show up
alongside a video you might watch are
paid for so let's say Clorox wants to
come along and put their ad alongside a
YouTube video they will pay YouTube to
put it there and YouTube will split that
payment with the uploader of the video
that's kind of basically how it works
and if you're a tech company
specifically you can pay a little more
to just be alongside Tech videos and
Tech channels and there's a whole Google
AdSense program for how this works but
that's the basics of it and that's a
huge part of YouTube's revenue and
YouTube's business model so in the
second bucket is creators can sell ads
themselves and so they can sell more
specific ads and read them inside of
their own videos a lot of times this is
better integrated and these work better
and more tailored to specific audiences
and can have better analytics and
there's all sorts of advantages and
that's why they often cost more but
that's number two is creators doing that
sale themselves but then number three
outside of ads is creators can sell
things they have a direct relationship
with their audience and so products or
things that are not just free content
which is what we make on YouTube can be
additional sources of revenue for a
Creator So Paid content for example on
only fans or patreon
I don't do those but you know they're
available and then you can do products
things like icons things like
lttstore.com or a beast Burger there's
plenty of great examples of this and
it's definitely just the beginning so I
won't even get into all the taxes and
insurance and payroll and all the the
super fun stuff but fundamentally we
make free content that is supported in
various ways either by ads or by the
audience directly I see I see okay so so
companies you will just send you stuff
is that right so yes honestly it's a
pretty structured relationship now in
2021 it hasn't always been this way but
now in Tech YouTube or with tech video
creators we're often basically treated
essentially the same way as Tech
journalists have been so when a new
piece of technology some product is
coming out for example the company that
makes it of course they want as many
eyeballs on it as possible but they'll
send it out to Tech media which includes
video creators on YouTube a little bit
early just so they can test it out and
use it now there is a risk to this
because hey if the product turns out to
be not very good then there will be a
lot of negative things said about it
right when it comes out but generally
this is good for the company if it's a
good product because then you get a nice
wave of positive coverage right at the
Embargo yeah okay that makes perfect
sense
but that word
what is an embargo okay so if you've
paid any attention to Tech news for any
length of time you've probably noticed
every once in a while if it will be a
moment a certain time when a bunch of
things all get released at once about
the same device when like all of the
reviews or all the unboxings for
something drop at the same time and
every time there's a bunch of comments
about it like thinking was this
orchestrated how did you plan this is
this a coincidence so to try to keep it
simple uh when we test something early
before it's been revealed to the world
we all have to sign a document that says
that when we're testing it we will also
keep it a secret so that we don't reveal
it to the world before the company does
and so we're allowed to do all our
testing and use it and figure out what's
good and bad about it but this document
has a date and a time when it expires
that's when we're also allowed to say
what we found and our thoughts and so
naturally if you want to be in that
first wave of coverage you're publishing
your stuff right at the beginning that's
when people will search for it and we'll
view it but the document itself is
called an NDA a non-disclosure agreement
and generally that moment when the door
is open when we're allowed to talk about
our experience is an embargo there's
lots of them
so do get to keep all that stuff so
sometimes yes sometimes no like it
depends on the company and like what the
thing is like I've reviewed several cars
here on the channel in the past of
course it doesn't make sense
for cars to just be sitting around here
so of course they'll go back to the
company and they'll move them on to the
next reviewer who can use it but
sometimes they do sometimes they do sit
around here it is useful to have things
maybe one or two generations older to
physically compare them when we're doing
our testing but generally yeah we uh we
find a good use for stuff and if your
next question was well can I have one of
the things uh we don't really just give
them away so we make good use of it also
we do often end up buying the thing
after the review process so we get the
thing we review it we send it back and
then we buy one which means we can
compare it later when the next gen comes
out so okay I got a question how do you
decide what to make a video about so
this is different for every single
creator for sure like I kind of find
it's like asking a basketball player how
he chooses what shot to take you know
you've got your go-to's you got your
go-to's but you're definitely always
probing for the best available options
now the thing about being a tech Channel
is we have a pretty big Advantage which
is we make videos about products and so
the subject of the video is the product
so it's not really on me to be
interesting like it's a bonus if the the
host of the tech video is interesting
but it's really on the tech industry to
keep making the most interesting
compelling new stuff that's their
advantage they've got to make a great
new folding phone electric car motors
gadgets there's kind of there's stuff
happening all the time and so I can
point a camera at it and if we get good
at that then we're doing our job
honestly sometimes the biggest challenge
isn't coming up with the video to make
but actually making the video itself a
lot of people watch a 12 minute video
and think well how long could that have
taken to make 12 minutes like people
really think that but that you know
there's a process of writing and
research and testing before shooting
before editing and it can often take
days sometimes weeks for videos and so
yeah it does take quite a bit of time
there's lots of videos I'd like to do
but we're working on other stuff so
that's I mean
how do you learn to do this do you go to
school for this so with most people I
know
no they didn't go to school for it now
today you know in 2021 there are some
video production classes there are some
social media classes there are some
entrepreneurship and and business
classes
and I'm sure you could combine them all
in just the right way to make a sort of
creative major but generally from what
I've seen uh yeah most of it is
self-taught closest thing I can think of
actually is we actually made a
skillshare course that goes over the
creation of one of these MKBHD videos of
one of these reviews from scratch from
the pre-production and coming up with
ideas to actually shooting it and
editing it I'll leave a link below if
you want to check it out but yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if in the next
couple years or maybe this already
exists if there is like
you know YouTube
creation as a major in college that that
might be a thing someday if it isn't
already be pretty sick actually so
that's a that sounds like a fun job but
are you are you gonna do this forever
until you're old you're gonna do this
for a long time I think that's a hard
question probably for anybody to answer
but I do know they say if you love what
you do you never work a day in your life
partially true uh it's definitely still
work but I'd like to do this as long as
I enjoy it as long as it's fun I might
have already heard that Creator burnout
is a real thing very real don't get me
wrong
um like I said I feel fortunate that the
thing that is the subject of my videos
is its own thing it's Tech and I'm
interested in that but yeah there's uh
if you get tired of regular job you can
kind of keep going but if you're an
independent Creator and you run out of
ideas or you you have this writer's
block or or creative burnout it can feel
like oh if I step off the path how do I
get back on so it is a it is a
particular concern 2021 but
as long as I'm having fun
I'm gonna keep doing it I think if
there's a day that I ever I'm not having
fun making Tech videos something went
very wrong you know what that sounds
like a lot of fun that sounds fun good I
want to do that could I do that I want
to do that you know what absolutely yes
yes anyone yes you can be a YouTuber
today I actually read that uh the number
one new job the number one job a lot of
young people want today isn't astronaut
it isn't pro athlete it is an actor or
policeman anymore it's YouTuber which is
crazy to me because in 2009 you know
starting this literally zero people had
this as a job nobody was making a living
making videos on the internet but here's
what I'll say turning YouTube into a job
is kind of like sports kind of like
basketball take basketball for example
right it's never been easier to play
basketball to pick up basketball for the
first time all you need is a ball and a
hoop basically and you can go play you
can play in a park you can play in your
backyard you can play in a league in a
gym somewhere
but that's not doing it as a job and
it's the same it feels the same as with
any creative Endeavor but especially
with making videos and putting them on
YouTube it's never been easier to grab a
camera the one you have on your
smartphone to start making shooting
videos editing videos all of that the
barrier for entry has never been lower
but like basketball there's a very small
number of people relatively that have
combined luck and timing and of course
hard work and dedication and skill to be
able to turn it into their job and doing
it for a living but it's it feels almost
like like two different categories of
the same activity so my advice for
people asking is always if you want to
start doing YouTube uh imagine it like
basketball in the park like if you could
have fun doing that every day and never
making a dime off of it you're gonna
have a great time it's fun but I
wouldn't set that expectation of turning
that into a job there's a lot more that
comes with actually deciding you want to
be a YouTuber instead of just uh signing
up and getting right going from the from
the get-go so something to keep in mind
oh yeah you know what I did see I saw
your video about the this S21 but okay
what do you really think about it it's
actually real I've had people literally
come up to me and say they've watched a
video and want to know what I think of
the thing but that's the thing
that's the review that's I did that for
you I made that so you could know what I
thought of the thing now if you're ever
curious about the nuances or want to dig
into the details of how coverage works
or what's what's paid versus what isn't
paid on this channel uh recommend this
video you can check out that I made
specifically about that but yeah that's
it that's that's pretty much the top
10 questions that I get about being a
YouTuber and now this is the video I'm
going to send to people who ask me those
questions so that they can get all the
information in one place maybe you'll
send it to them too thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
what are you going to the city for
uh work for work
ah of course yeah what do you do for
work I do I do video production
I'm a cameraman
I do news radio